you have a ranch now you live on a ranch
yeah live in Texas you live in Texas 50
acres or something crazy like that right
and that sounds nice to me yeah
obviously I was reading about your life
your wife is an ex model she still
modeling still modeling beautiful got
the kids got animals on the farm that's
all I want
mm-hmm what more do you want supermodel
animals and fifty acres really the [ __ ]
else is there in life
am I correct I'm doing all right yeah
yeah I'm doing okay where'd you meet
this wife of yours the coachella no I
met here I met her here
no Kenny hello I thought that's where
everyone goes to meet their supermodel
wife Coachella isn't that the place we
actually that's what do you say that
because because that's how I got her I
flew her out I was like hey you know
we've kind of seen each other a little
bit I was I come to Coachella come see
your boy right quick so yeah really kind
of leaked I mean you're wrong man that's
funny
let me tell you something if I could
play guitar every woman I was slightly
interested in would be flown out to
Coachella see me at my best
there would be no tickets for a regular
people no audience of your potential and
what goes on in the ranch
are you milking cows are you how far
into this are you I mean you're a great
artist I don't know I'm saying I'm not
out there doing anything crazy like that
but um yeah it's just like what are you
doing to like when you're not on tour
you wake up in the morning a you know
you look at your wife for a while and
then then there are chores to be done on
a farm right I mean that's tough to do
but we got a we got some help oh you do
you got a whole set up we got a little
bit of dad I want to be on a farm but
not have to do anything you know what I
mean I have to come visit you yeah come
through